it's 6 a.m
oh
i only get up early for really awesome
things
[Music]
well good morning it is early early
early on a monday morning and i'm
driving five hours to north carolina's
outer banks to do some spear fishing i
found a charter that's gonna take me out
spear fishing and uh
i am super new at spear fishing but i am
wild about it i got into it this year we
went down to florida and spearfished
lionfish
and then we went out in june to hawaii
and i did four spear fishing trips out
there and i just love it i literally
don't know if i'm going to be diving on
rex or reefs or blue water or
what
all right we made
how's it going i'm i'm excited to go
poke a fish sweet we are too
all right
all right i'm here in the outer banks
and i'm here with quentin and dave with
vicarious fishing charters and uh we're
gonna go poke a fish what a beautiful
day we've had nasty weather with all
sorts of offshore hurricanes and stuff
like that we got this little window of
beauty here and uh
i'm excited to see what happens
oh what gorgeous weather this is perfect
so we're starting to say goodbye to the
shore and i've never swam out in the
open ocean before this is going to be
interesting
well here we go guys we're out in the
middle of nowhere
look around
nothing but blue in a boat
drove over a little bit of structure
with some fish on it we're gonna throw a
marker buoy on the top and uh
we're gonna give this a go
honestly i don't know what's more
unnerving the fact that i can't see the
shore
or that i can't see the bottom
all right guys let me show you my first
dive it's in 75 feet of water and i dove
down about 12 15 feet and found this
school of enormous spade fish just
swimming right there and i made my first
mistake of the dive
i kept the safety on
i fixed that problem
i got a spade fish right there
yeah that's a perfect shot that's right
where you want to shoot them
this next dive was one of the creepiest
and most disorienting things i've done a
long time you dive down into this murky
water and there's nothing to look at
nothing to gauge your direction or your
orientation and i had my dive watch and
i had to use that to tell i was even
going down and so i go down about 29
feet and i start to come up
and i see this crazy school of fish
swims right in front of me
without a dive watch i would have had no
idea how deep i was
this was so disorienting
this is also the first time i've ever
used a reel on a spear gun and so it's
really nice to be able to shoot this
little fish here and to kind of
get it figured out and try it out for
the first time
yeah pretty little guy
so is that a blue runner
oh yeah
we shot a couple nice little fish there
but uh the visibility wasn't great so
we're gonna go try another spot real
quick see if we can get some better
visibility and maybe some bigger fish
oh
when we landed in the second spot we
were immediately greeted by this big
ball of bait fish came right around us
and then this 40-pound barracuda swam
right in front of me and there was three
more underneath me and this makes me a
little nervous because i knew a guy that
got his kneecap bitten off by a
barracuda so that was all i was thinking
about as i saw his barracuda but once
you dove down on the first 10-15 feet
the visibility got a lot better and i
could see these pilings i was diving
next to and you could kind of start
seeing all these fish and get yourself
oriented and it was just awesome
suddenly two cobia right there just swam
right past me and i'm like what the heck
and i look and there's a couple good
sized jacks and i totally scared him
away by pointing my gun at him and then
a school of cobia swims right up to me
oh i just barely nicked the skin on the
top of his head and then the spear
almost immediately tore out but not
before that cobia nearly ripped that
spear out of my hand so i learned real
quick to calm down and focus on my shots
and loosen the drag on my reel yeah he
pulled out though
well i'll tell you what nothing gets
your mind off of psychotic man-eating
barracudas like seeing enormous cobia so
i was a lot more calm on my second dive
and it was just awesome to go down 40
feet and see so many fish down here it
was
better than i had even dreamed
the water was just so much clearer down
here and there was so many fish around
me i was just kind of taking it all in
and i looked behind me and suddenly
there's all these massive fish swimming
up behind me and on this shot i was just
more focused and decisive
this is my first time shooting a large
fish and it was intimidating you really
got to have your drag set loose on your
wheel because you don't want to get in a
tug of war match 40 feet under the
surface
once you get to the surface that's when
the fight starts you get up there and
you're hand lining this thing and just
lines going everywhere and everyone's
telling us don't get tangled in your
line don't get tangled in your line but
it's easier said than done because these
fish go bonkers
that's the stuff right there buddy
that's nice that's why 18 20 pounds
maybe
look at that
my very first cobia ever i've never
caught a cobia before
that's a fun fish
see i couldn't resist i was just gonna
drop to like 20 feet to look around and
you slap right onto it i could have
touched it with my spear you know
oh that's a monster
look at that
oh that is a monster look at those
beautiful
fish and the hat is a beast of a joke
look at that
that is a beast
in north carolina you're only allowed
one cobia so my next dive was all about
getting one of those big amber jacks i
saw swimming around down there
you know this was starting to feel real
comfortable i was getting my gun figured
out i was getting my reel figured out
i'd actually tackled a big fish so i
dove down here i was only about 20 feet
under
saw a big old amberjack
everything about this dive went so
smoothly i was like this is easy i got
this little did i know that this average
act was going to try to murder me
you know how i told you you're not
supposed to get tangled up in your spear
line well it's really hard when an
amberjack is swimming circles around you
with a spear sticking out of its head
this amberjack has completely wrapped
the cable around my throat and is trying
to strangle me together i'm being
garrotted by an amberjack
fun fact this is actually the second
time somebody has tried to strangle me
while i was swimming
yeah he was pretty well i bet he wasn't
okay he's acting a little more chill
just like i said he's super chill
i mean that that was only 21 feet so you
know i've only had to dive like 29 feet
34 feet 41 feet 21 feet i mean this is
this is great i think all my dives have
been under a minute well now it limited
out on amberjack as well as cobia so i
got my pull spear out i decided i was
gonna go try poking some of those spade
fish and some of those amico jacks with
my pull spear
i was so jazzed to get a chance to pull
out my pull spear i love using this
thing and oh hey look there's a big old
spooky barracuda i wasn't even afraid
look at me
on this dive it went down about 45 feet
and it was just awesome i was targeting
those little albico jacks or maybe even
a spade fish
i really wasn't looking to start any
fights i couldn't finish with that pull
spear
man i just can't get over how chill
these fish are they just didn't mind me
coming right up to him
shooting these little albico jacks with
the pulse we are so much fun they're not
going to strangle you to death with your
cold spear
foreign
the tip of that pulse here is kind of
shiny it's kind of twitching a little
bit but he comes over and just about ate
it
by this time i had already shot six fish
and we had about 50 something pounds of
fish in the cooler it just been an
amazing day and quentin dived down
alongside me and got a little bit of
footage of me diving which was really
cool
guys what an awesome day man this cooler
is full of fish
look at this
tons of fish loads of fun
and it wasn't as hard and technical of
diving as i thought it was going to be
which was a real relief for a beginner
like myself listen if you guys want to
do this too
make sure to check out vicarius charters
i'm gonna put their information in the
video description down below if you guys
want to come down to the outer banks and
try this out but we got a load of fish
to clean and a load of fish to cook up i
think we have to invite some friends
over
throw a little party
oh yeah
that's not too bad 24.
[Music]
all right that amberjack was about 20
pounds that's not bad when you get two
fish over 20 that's a good day no matter
what you're doing yeah i didn't get
footage of this but uh while i was
putting around with my little pokey
pokey stick here this guy was
catching spanish mackerel and little
albacore tuna on light tackle
tons of fun
that looked awesome caught that on that
little dinky rod over there that's the
good time even if you can't spearfish
come out
that's right tell me that.com
[Music]
like a catch-and-release fisherman so i
i uh
i am i nobody wants to watch me do it do
you like the dexter russell nice yeah
man
easy to clean up too
i've never eaten a cobia either so this
is a lot of my first cobia oh yeah basic
white meat huh
[Music]
oh
these little jacks look pretty good
that should work
[Music]
all right
wow guys that was so much fun and i was
a little worried that this was going to
be a little bit too challenging for my
skill level and it was perfect i had
such a good time so glad i did this
but now we got to pay the piper and
drive five hours back home
oh
we're gonna cook up so much fish
tomorrow it's gonna be a good time we're
biting everyone over
we made it back to the house and now
it's time to cook some fish we're gonna
have a big old fish dinner party here at
the house tonight i'm gonna be cooking
up all the fish all right guys we're
making three different recipes first
recipe we're gonna do indian style fish
curry it's gonna be good
[Music]
[Laughter]
there we go fish curry
looking and smelling good all right for
our second recipe we're doing cobia fish
and chips oh yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
all right guys we're gonna cook up the
amberjack with just some panko and lemon
zest it's gonna be good
[Music]
hey all right there we go it was a bit
hectic but we got everything cooked not
too bad for a school night thank you but
um let's taste it see what it's like
yeah sure um
do you like your fish and chips
yeah what do you think what was your
favorite and so far i've had this spade
fish curry and it was hit i really like
it turned out really well since i tried
the
fish and chips and i've never had them
before they're great the sweet chili
sauce is amazing isn't it it's really
really good goes on everything i had
such a great time with the spear fishing
the food it was all wonderful we hope
you guys enjoyed this video just as much
as we enjoyed eating this fish if you
guys want to see more catch and cook
videos check out our catch and cook
playlist
and uh
i've got a kitchen to clean up see you
next saturday
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every saturday morning and hit
that bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching